john means there he is making his 20th
appearance of the year you know the
story spent six weeks on the il those 12
starts before the i o he had a 2.28 era
the seven start since coming off the il
era just below six so here's nelson cruz
with one away
and down he goes a breaking ball
number two how about this curve ball
really good when it's a strike out of
the hands but as it travels towards home
plate it is down and in and under the
bat here's wander franco first pitch
swinging franco powers one to right
santander back at the warning track
he'll make the catch so a one two three
first inning for john means for the
tampa bay rays here tonight it's going
to be right-hander michael walker making
his 18th start of the season record of
two and four era of 588 90 and the third
innings of work
and he goes up and gets him on strikes
96 up a little bit out of the zone two
gone base is empty and here's anthony
santander here's a swing and a miss of
the ball down in the dirt kicked around
a little bit by
santander now picked up by me and he
throws the first in time and that will
retire the sun rays and orioles
scoreless base runner this afternoon
here's yandy diaz to bet
got him down on strikes 94 on the
fastball second strikeout for means one
out here in the second and then lao
steps in wow
swings and misses strike three the throw
down to first completes the strikeout
three strikeouts for john means two down
johnny means how's it going right now a
good fastball it's up to 95 sitting
around 94 and how about this breaking
ball dj stewart steps in 11 homers 30
driven in on the year
bounce to the right side and off the
glove
steward will reach
luplow got leather on it but couldn't
corral it we'll see how it scored but dj
stewart on it first with one down yeah
i'm thinking this one's gonna go down to
the base hit breaking ball kind of left
out over to play dj stewart goes out and
hooks it luke lowe playing over at first
base lays out the ball just tips off his
glove at that point here's ramona
swing and a miss saw a strikeout
strikeout number three
nine hole hitter kevin
here's a swing and a line drive past the
reach of mateo on the right for a base
hit so lefty on lefty care myers sends a
streaking lighter to the right side of
the game field and the race have their
first hit of the night and thus
completes one full time through the
order for john means
doubled up on him means off the bound
gonna have to hurry fires and gets him
nice play from john means so after the
infield hit the pop-up and we swing back
around to the top of the lineup with
cedric mullins
full count trust mullins to put the ball
in play
he's on the move and he is
in there he avoided the tag bronco could
not find him and mateo is in there
and mejia is not real happy because the
throw beat him by plenty this should be
a strike amount thrown out it's not even
close two out walk runners at first and
second for anthony santander he lifted
in the air into shallow left late break
for rose arena still coming on and makes
the running catch randy rosarina
utilizing his speed to take that pop-up
away top of the fourth inning john means
out for another round 0-2 to cruise
fastball strike three crews frozen two
and two to diaz and the pitch bringing
the grounder outside that's a fair ball
and all the way down the left field line
running forever to go chasing in the
corner of stewart and diaz around second
and he is pulled in with a double rays
have a man in scoring position for the
first time
wow pops it up again severino with the
mask off this one is way into the night
sky he calls off gutierrez makes the
catch backs up his battery main lead off
double 14th double the year by severino
here's jorge mateo now the pitch swing
and a miss
he
struck him out a big k for waka he gets
the out without the runner advancing
well it's a walk to gutierrez so
the orioles have two on with one down
and they're going to the top of the
order in cedric mullins and kevin cash
is going to go out with the hook
left-handed adam conley will make his
sixth appearance for the raid 2-2 did it
hit him
yes it is it did cedric mullins hit by a
pitch and now the bases are loaded and
the orioles have loaded him up with one
out but here's mount castle swing and a
fly ball out to left to rosarina back at
the track at the wall he makes the catch
backing into the fence throws behind a
second
where gutierrez scampers back as
severino crosses standing up from third
a rose arena tracked it down at the wall
but the orioles strike first on a
mountain castle sac fly i mean john
means is working quick fielders like
that yeah he's confident about what he's
doing him and pedro savarino seem to be
right on the same page
he got him looking dropped in the change
this is the one after a fastball that
will definitely hurt your feelings he
struck out cruz twice one two cruz pops
this one up severino again mask off
in front of home he'll pause and it's
kelvin gutierrez who comes down the line
makes the call and the out one two three
inning for john means austin hayes pinch
hitting for dj stewart
that's it well right field drifting back
margot it's off the wall can't get it
hayes around second he'll get to third
austin hayes in with a triple with one
down here in the orioles sixth
austin hayes captain clutch
he puts a runner 90 feet from home so
now the orioles with runners at first
and third for pedro severino only one
strike pitch that's it well that'll get
him in
over the head of rosarina
and the orioles take a two nothing lead
now they throw to third and a good job
severino moves up to second pedro
with his second double of the game and
the birds lead it two nothing now second
and third a tail center field looping
and it's in for a base hit that'll get
one in severino stops at third
and the orioles lead it three-nothing as
jorge mateo delivers orioles have a
three-nothing lead for john means 2-2
rip torias backhand side
snares it couldn't hit it any harder
one down and suddenly the rays have
something cooking
second and third one out in the seventh
to the bullpen go the orioles john means
leaves with a zero on the board next to
tampa bay and he'll give way to dylan
tate dylan tate making his 48th
appearance well margot is due and
meadows will pinch it for him
the pitch is grounded to the right side
over to mount castle the run scores diaz
crosses the plate the reigns are on the
board wow goes to third now there is
going to hit joey wendell for jordan
luplow
into left field that's going to be over
the head of hayes scoring loud
that makes it a three to two ball game
and wendell winds up at second
and the rays make it a one run contest
joey wendell will take over at third
base try again and this one is shot back
at third what a play by wendell throw to
first got him oh my
what a play by joey wendell back at
third he gets his man mount castle at
first wow
foul territory reaching over there
behind the bag
and still getting his man at first big
star on that play milwaukee to begin the
eighth and now you got a rosarian
that's up the right side is it going to
be fair that ball is
gone
that ball is a home run
it got over the wall
on a 2-1 pitch a rosarenda takes it to
the opposite field he didn't get it all
but he had plenty
and hit it over the wall
in right field and the rays have taken a
4-3 lead here's franco
and that's a looper in the center and
it's going to drop for a base set and
franco is aboard to extend his streak 28
games now he has reached base 28
straight games only player ahead of him
players 20 or younger with that on base
streak mickey mantle two outs bases
empty in the bottom of the ninth inning
kelvin gutierrez
and a cut in the miss that's going to do
it the rays win this one four to three
[Applause]